hello everyone welcome to a talk so
today gentlemen are going to talk about
a little bit about fundamental physics
project we are starting and mostly
they're going to talk about
infrastructure behind it specifically
the set replace package and as a call we
are building so the basic idea of the
final physics project is we are going to
try to find fundamental theory physics
using approach of a new kind of science
which means we assume that the universe
is produced as an evolution of a simple
system and specifically you want to pick
a system that has the least structure as
little structure as possible so
specifically the system we are going to
study at least at first is what we call
the cell substitution system so this is
kind of similar to graph rewrite systems
or networks of fusion systems but it's
simpler anyway because all it is is that
we have a set an ordered set as a state
of the system and then at each iteration
we take a subset of the set which
matches a particular pattern and we
replace it with something else so so we
have this function called set replace
and for example if you take set which is
1 2 3 4 we can replace 3 1 this a B and
we get 2 for a B of course we can use
patterns in the rule inputs as well so
in this case for example we take two odd
numbers and replace and with a sum and
the interesting thing start happening
when the elements of the set have some
relationship between them so in
particular simple case would be suppose
each element of the set is a pair of
numbers which makes it a graph well
directed graph in particular and we can
take a path graph for example and then
we can specify rules that would take two
adjacent edges and replace them with a
single edge and after two steps we just
get one for here from this
and we can do the opposites in as well
we can introduce new your decisions the
right-hand side of the rule by Putin
module in it in this case we are
creating new your text on the right-hand
side of the rule and we'll replace one
edge these two edges inserting this your
text in the middle and we get this
structure I mean we get this path graph
as a new I mean new variables were
created by the module now because it's
kind of complicated to write this module
every time we also have a short notation
for those rules in which case we just
use numbers and all the numbers on the
left-hand side of the rule replace these
patterns and if the new numbers appear
on the right-hand side of the rules and
model module is inserted automatically
so in this case we get the same rule
here okay so for running the system for
a large number of steps it's actually
more convenient to use another function
which is called wall for model so which
this is the one we mostly use to analyze
the systems for physics purposes so if
you take a rule yeah you can take a
particular rule see looks like yeah
which takes three edges coming from the
same vertex and replaces them with this
kind of structure we can evolve it for
six steps where so for Wolfram model you
just specify the rule in terms of
numbers states we don't need to use to
pattern rules and then each step here
means we place all non-overlapping
subsets at once and then we get this
evolution object to it and we can ask
various things of this evolution object
such as for example we can ask it to
give us a state of the system after each
step and we get this evolution
in which produces things and exists at
the end okay so the number of properties
one can ask this evolution object so one
of the interesting ones is causal graph
which shows the network in which each
vertex is an event and we have an edge
between vertices if the output of one of
the events overlap is an input for
another in other words there is a causal
relationship between two events then we
put an edge in between them okay and
finally I want to talk about some
visualization functions we have so we
are currently developed in okay so if
yours I need to say that we can consider
hyper graphs as well on the systems
because the set can contain elements
which are not two vertices but more than
two edges so for example in this case we
have ordered hyper graph consisting of
three edges instead of two edges and the
very yeah so we can plot it and here
okay so this is what we call brain
electrical embedding so the way it works
is that it's similar to spring
electrical invasion we also simulate
this hyper edges together with vortices
and so in this case we have essentially
path graph consisting of three hyper
edges so it looks like that and if we
have so in this case we have two double
self loops which is 1 1 1 and then 1 1 1
on the other side and then we can have
things like that where is 1 3 3 3 5 5 &
5 & 1 and so on
yeah so this as this visualization is
not completely implemented yet so it's
not in the package but it's going to be
soon and this is an example of a large
graph it
okay so all all of this code I just
showed you except for as a typographical
ization is available on github in the
set replace package which you can find
from this link so you're welcome to you
know look at it and ask me any questions
later
and this I give it to Jonathan okay
thanks I'm now going to talk very very
briefly about how we can take one of
these sort of set substitution
hypergraph substitution systems and go
about deducing whether or not it
satisfies kind of reasonable
discretization of known laws of physics
so one thing we have to be able to do if
we want to be able to do this
efficiently is involved what are called
multi way systems so multi way systems
are sort of combinatorial structures
that occur when there is no kind of
canonical order in which to apply the
replacement operation so effectively one
applies all possible replacement orders
and one gets this sort of tree structure
hopefully actually not a tree structure
but something a little bit more
interesting than that which represents
all possible updating orders but one way
one thing you have to do if you want to
do that efficiently is determine when to
set substitution event when to say well
when to sort of hypergraph spatial
slices are equivalent which is
essentially a question of whether to
hyper graphs are isomorphic and so
fortunately I works on this problem
actually a few years ago and so we have
now reasonably fast implementations of
this so-called uniqueness tree algorithm
generalized for the hyper graft case so
you know here's an example of two hyper
graphs that are sort of trivially
isomorphic here are two hyper graphs
that is trivially non isomorphic we have
isomorphisms can be detected between
both hide between both ordered and
unordered hyper graphs which is sort of
the natural generalization of directed
and undirected graphs so you know here's
an example of two hyper graphs that are
isomorphic as under occurs unordered and
hyper graphs but but non isomorphic as
ordered ones and as well as just
detecting the presence of an isomorphism
where one exists we can also return
associations that sort of did that that
indicate the presence of those
isomorphisms and indicate kind of which
vertices can reasonably be mapped onto
which are the vertices
given the particular hyper edge
configuration the East
so given that we now have a way of
evolving these multi waste systems so
let me let me actually do that so that's
okay let me do this four steps so here's
a multi way system for this particular
set substitution rule and this is what
we get hit by fur Cates after a few
steps so let's do this for a little bit
longer and hopefully we'll get something
interesting so we start to get something
a little bit non-trivial here so you see
that there are a bunch of these
bifurcations where there's kind of
ambiguity in the updating order and then
there are places where these where these
points reconvert that effectively
different updating orders lead to sort
of spatial hypergraphs that end up being
isomorphic and in this particular case
they are they're being treated as as
ordered hypergraphs because that's the
that's sort of the main system that
we've been investigating so far and so
max already mentioned this notion of a
causal Network which is kind of the
discrete analogue of a space-time for
the for one of these things of each if
each hypergraph is essentially a spatial
space like hyper surface then the causal
network is the sort of gives you the
conformal structure of the entire
space-time so one question you can ask
is if you have a multi-way system does
every branch of the multi way system
yield a causal network web or do all
branches of the multi way system yield
causal networks that are all isomorphic
as undirected graphs this is a property
that Stephen first referred to in nks as
causal invariants and it's related to
the so called confluence or
church-rosser properties of abstract
rewrite systems and it's interesting
because at least in Stephens conception
of fundamental physics the this this
property of causal invariance is turns
out to be equivalent to Lorenz the
inverted Lorentz invariants because
effectively different possible updating
orders correspond to different possible
foliation zuv the state of the causal
network into space like hyper surfaces
and the constraint of causal invariance
is precisely the constraint that the
ordering of time like separated event is
invariant under the choice of
hypersurface
even if the ordering of space like
separated events is not so we thanks to
our efficient multi way system evolution
code we actually have also a very
efficient way of determining whether a
given candidate universe is causally
invariant it essentially has to do with
with computing what I called unreserve
using all critical pairs effectively all
bifurcations of the causal network and
then determining whether those critical
pairs will resolve after a finite number
of steps and there are a bunch of
product properties of abstract rewrite
systems that we kind of exploit in order
to do that so here this is a this is an
example of a multi-way evolution system
that ends up being causally invariant
and hence concer
with special relativity even though it's
kind of doing all of this complicated
bifurcation stuff and the reason for
that is that although it has a lot of
these critical players a lot of
bifurcations it turns out that if we
just run this computation we determined
that all of them eventually resolve okay
here's a here's a a trivial example of a
multi-way system I don't know why that
edge ended up that vertex ended up being
so big that that is actually non
confluent and hence non causally
invariant because it has it has a
bifurcation that ends up not fully
resolving I'm not sure what happened
here something's gone wrong with the
visualization but
okay let me try this this one work yes
okay forget that example we would be
prepared about five minutes before the
lecture so here's actually an instance
of a substitution system that Stephen
discovered in one of his various
enumerations it seems to do extremely
bizarre things and it produces a causal
network that has a very rich structure
with you know say lots of bifurcation
lots of sort of reconvergence is but
it's not entirely clear what's happening
or if what's going on is actually
relativistically invariant but it turns
out that I mean it's a reasonably
crunchy computation to figure this out
it turns out to be non causally
invariant in this particular case
because there are certain critical pairs
of this remote system to end up not not
fully rican verging ok so is there a
generalization of this approach well
there sort of is one thing is if we want
to do this search systematically we want
to use something that's kind of better
for heuristic better than heuristics for
determining whether a candidate universe
is kind of hopeful or not because if you
have a heuristic it's gonna miss things
and and it would be it would be really
really embarrassing if we actually
missed kind of finding our universe
because of a faulty heuristic in one of
these enumerations and so instead what
we want to be able to do is have kind of
provably hopeless cases so that there
are a bunch of cases where just on the
basis of the combinatorial structure of
the rule we can determine things about
whether it's wet whether it even has a
hope of being consistent with certain
laws of physics so one of these is
causal invariance as I already mentioned
one of these is you know whether whether
the the network limits to a kind of
fixed dimensional manifold so okay this
gets a little bit complicated and that
there are sort of discrete romani and
geometry kind of ideas that that I'd
have to explain in order to detail this
fully but essentially the idea is thank
you if you're if you're if you're given
a network and you want to determine kind
of what's the dimensionality of the
space that it might represent you know
one way you can do that is you just pick
a point and then you go out at you
assign every every edge sort of unit
distance and you figure out what's
what's the total number of vertices that
you can reach from a distance R of a
given vertex and then you know for a
network that corresponds to two
dimensional space you expect it to grow
like r-squared for a three dimensional
the expected likely to grow like R cubed
and generally in D dimensional space you
expected to grow like R to the D which
is true if it's a kind of flat space you
know in the in the two dimensional case
that would be a network that's just a
kind of just a trivalent network of
hexagons
but if you add in Pentagon's or
heptagons that is correspond to the
discrete notion of positive and negative
curvature then there's a correction
factor and the correction factor turns
out to be proportional to a
discretization of the Ricci scalar
curvature called the Olivier Ricci
curvature and then you could you can go
a little bit further and you can look at
kind of growth rates of volumes of
space-time cones and causal networks
that turn out to be proportional to
projections of the of the discreet Ricci
tensor and you can derive a whole bunch
of constraints on this and they turn out
to be equivalent to the Einstein
equations so because of that we we have
ways of determining you know given a set
substitution system it doesn't have a
hope of satisfying the Einstein
equations and one of the one of the key
postulates that you need in order for
that whole whole derivation to work is
that the causal network has to limit to
a to a finite dimensional manifold and
so we again we need to have efficient
ways of determining whether that's true
without having to evolve this rule for
potentially millions of steps before we
discard it
so one approach we have to doing that is
using automated theorem proving
algorithms so basically taking some of
the automate if they're improving
infrastructure we already have in the
Wolfram language and generalizing it to
the case of hypergraph substitution
systems which is just like any other
kind of substitution system and hence we
by having a kind of specialized Network
logic with the axioms that correspond to
this but these substitution systems we
can actually prove theorems about them
without having to evolve the whole
system so at least in certain cases or
in a large class of cases we can prove
very quickly that ok this this causal
you know the causal network that's going
to be generated by by this particular
set substitution system is not going to
be compatible with causal in various or
we can say that the the manifold the
limits out of this is not going to have
a fixed number of dimensions or okay so
some cases that might be easier to sort
of understand it would be if we can
prove that the causal network for a
given set substitution system is always
going to be a tree that's another way of
saying that there can be no non-trivial
interactions between distinct points in
space and so we can kind of discard that
we know without too much without too
much hassle or another instance of a
situation where we know that there can
be known no interesting sort of
interactions would be one where we can
prove that the substitution system
produces a a spatial hyper graph which
could also have been produced by a by a
neighborhood independent substitution
system because effectively that's saying
that there are no local interactions
that occur in that universe so that's
another case where we know it's hopeless
so to do that we've we've introduced
this over we're starting to introduce a
whole bunch of these automated theorem
proving algorithms so here's an example
of a substitution rule in this case
corresponds to a simple under direct
network substitution rule and here's a
particular pattern that we want to be
able to show always occurs independent
of how the rules overlap and independent
of how the pattern is embedded into the
rest of the network you know that's
something that if you were just gave you
were just told this this fact and asked
to determine if whether or not it was
true it would take you quite a long time
even if you had a computer to kind of
evolve this thing to determine whether
that was whether that was actually valid
because there are a lot of different
ways that the rules can overlap with
each other there are lots of different
ways that this pattern can be embedded
but fortunately we have these do these
algorithms now which with a reasonably
short amount of time can synthesize
these formal proofs this particular 1/2
happen to have 41 steps in it we get
back the symbolic proof graph that shows
the the chain of deduction there and so
now in this particular case that means
we can discard this universe kind of
with with impunity right we cuz we if we
want to we could have some kind of
universe landfill where we just say this
is you know universe number 231 provably
not our universe and we can actually
specify the proof graph as a kind of
seal to say you know you can go verify
this if you want and you could run the
proof function and confirm all of this
stuff okay so I think that's everything
we wanted to say at least for the moment
so that I mean we ought to say perhaps
Stephen is planning to make an
announcement about this project at some
point I think in the next couple of
months and and what's once we do that
like a lot more of the information about
the actual physics of these models will
become available right now you know we
tried to keep this talk reasonably
focused on the actual kind of underlying
software and infrastructure and the
tools that were using for searching and
and filtering these universes but
hopefully yeah they'll be there'll be
more information about the actual kind
of underlying network science of these
things available in the near future and
max was there anything else you want to
say or okay well thank you very much
[Applause]